but trying to get this guy on the
podcast for a while
recently he's had some time free up a
lot of time
i introduced yourself to the universe
man hey what's up man malik b
you might know me aka rolly boy the
rolly boy is here you got the rolex
roll actually i mean it's all good um
yeah man i'm here i'm happy to be
listen kevin hit me up and he knows like
hey bro i'm trying to i'm trying to work
with me please
yeah and then it's like bro but you stay
consistent you know that's what i love
about i'm like bro please work with me
you understand my schedule he did yeah
he was on the road
on the road everything he was like yo
okay it's a perfect time to hit him up
and i was like yo
i was like all right yeah let's do it um
how long i mean
for people who don't know like obviously
you're doing you're
huge in the stand-up world now but you
have like a
uh you started you were fighting prior
you were boxing all my life um you still
like do you still
you know train and stuff like that um
how did you transition from boxing to
comedy or was there where did they
always kind of go hand in hand it was
always hand-in-hand but
uh i tried from boxing i went to a lot
of people don't notice
i wouldn't i always was boxing and
acting at the time yeah i saw your uh
your like your
your your you know your shot your i when
i googled your name i just hit images
and you had your like you know your
glamour shots
what are they called your head shots
yeah i was like you look at this
[ __ ] right he looks like a
they play it see listen if you let
hollywood do you any like tell you
anything
you go for it those head shots let's get
that out the way bro
uh they played me they were like bro lay
down and make your face like this this
is what the cast
looks like a 90s r b series
yeah you look good like that and there
was a dude taking a picture and i fell
off of course it was yeah he was like yo
i'm butting that little top
but again um so i went to from boxing i
went to
movies like uh so my first role was
creed
yeah and and uh shout out to michael b
jordan killing it uh
he's like another guy that put people on
and he saw me in the gym he was like bro
you got personality and you can box yo
you want to like audition for this movie
right
i was like bro yeah i'd love to i i i
was acting and all that so
i did it he was like bro you really
connect and he just like guided me on
set
cool dude and from that like experience
propelled me to do this
netflix original movie called bernie
sands
and from bernie sanders they was like
bro you funny as hell right right
so you recent recently got into stand-up
yeah so this is my third year
wow number three what is like um because
for
i think stand-up has to be one of the
scariest things to like
do especially like it feels like you're
like it's instant gratification like you
know whether or not you suck off the rip
there's people
there's people in front of you you know
what i'm saying like you could do
something on youtube and upload it and
you know what i'm saying just see what
happens yeah exactly
stand up is like how like like you know
you've gotten really good at it but like
how nervous
were you like initially to get into
something like that i'll be honest i
wasn't
nervous at all really when you know
having a guy across from across the ring
from you try to
literally knock your head off is the
scariest thing you ever experienced so
if you like i like that like this well
they not hitting you right they're like
yo dodge punches and
again it's just like what do you feel
that's funny and i always had so i took
that boxing confidence and put it on
stage
even if i didn't have jokes right and
that was funny to the audience
so um i was like oh i got something here
and i took a stand up but if anything i
want to dye my eyes across
my teeth so i took a stand-up class
before i even like hit an open mic
before i did it so i remember the first
day i got to the class it was like okay
everyone has to do three minutes if you
even if you don't have to you don't have
three minutes i was like oh [ __ ]
and then i was like all right well i
watched everyone go and i'm in the class
where like people have been doing it for
like three five six years like now
personality got to take over
yeah personality got to take over i was
like but you know what i noticed
if you be honest they will love you so
then i was like uh
my first joke was man after saying y'all
said [ __ ] i'm trash
and then they was like well hold on you
know and i just started talking and i
started talking about like
you know relationships and i have jokes
with my confidence right right
and i started writing and they teach you
how the structure of the joke and that's
how i got into
everything still fight though just look
to the viewers
you're still fighting still fighting um
i know you got a lot of rappers tuning
in when you when you initially met
uh michael b jordan was that when he was
training for creed
yeah yeah dude was yoked up and i was
skinny you know boxing shape so i used
to walk around like 150
150 you know 160 in that range and it
was yoked up
he was just watching because he was
studying a role i remember i seen him in
fl uh floyd mayweather
yeah so this is like i see now you know
i'm like hey what's up wallace
you know because right right yeah shout
out to the wire yeah shout out to the
wire bro you know what's crazy is i just
rewatched the wire
uh probably for the first time in a
decade during the pandemic and i totally
forgot
i i was like oh [ __ ] yeah that's michael
b
jordan peter wallace
yo what wallace huh my girlfriend yeah
my girl was like
she she's never seen the wire so i was
like yo we gotta watch it
yeah yeah well we watched it during the
pandemic yeah i'm about to say brother
sometimes you gotta that's why i do i
see my girl down at first i give it to
you
we gotta watch the wire we gotta watch
the wire i watch that annually every
year
that's so good man yeah around this
summertime to get you like your mind set
ready for what you got to go out there i
think
is it do you think the wire is the
greatest show ever yeah me too
is that or the sopranos i think the
three
i think one is undeniably the wire and
then two or three you could
say either breaking bad or sopranos
either order okay but breaking bad i
watched it and i was like you know i
watched one episode and i was like i can
do it out but i know i'm not
you never finished it no because a
teacher cooking math i'm like come on i
mean
you never finished breaking bad i'm
gonna be honest with you i know yeah
that's just something that didn't i
didn't like you gotta stick with it man
i mean listen it's crazy i don't have
anything to do with meth i don't even
wanna be over there in the streets
so just keep me with the crack and i'm
good the wire's about
you know you got something to do with my
man you got a lot of dope fees in
louisiana so
yeah hey you know what's so crazy i
don't know if you saw on twitter
uh they were trying to compare snowfall
to the wire and they're crazy
they're crazy bro
bro i swear to god i kept seeing like
memes saying what's better i'm like bro
snowfall is not it's a great show it is
not [ __ ] with the wire on its best
day
listen man franklin state could not
survive on bodies corner
everybody knows that everybody knows
bodhi was the warrior
all right yeah he and he lasted the
longest he lasted long and he was the
realest
yeah i mean even when lil kev got popped
that's a hard name for you but
you know kev was talking too much yo
that was a crazy uh
you know what's crazy too is i
appreciated season two so much more
because when yeah because when you first
like the first time you ever watched the
wire see
like you get through season one you're
like oh [ __ ] then season two happens
and it's like all kinds of new [ __ ]
going on and well we needed that though
but it was so good it was so good
honestly if you re-watch it
season two is like one of them it's one
of the best seasons man it's an
introduction to the greeks
and i'm like damn it's so important
because i was like now put everything
when you hear when you see a beautiful
written series it's just like man
yeah i don't know if i don't know if a
show will ever top the wire honestly
david simon is a genius
yeah i feel like um just kind of like
how themed out every season was like
like it was too smart of a show
too because i feel like it didn't get
the the flowers it deserved
until after it was over and people got
to really sit down with the series
yeah when it was on dvd and [ __ ] cuz i
feel like when it was like live
like people [ __ ] with it but the
people who [ __ ] with it was like a
very niche
type of person but after it finished and
everything
that's when it kind of and that's why
you gotta yeah i agree with everything
you're saying i remember my dad used to
in louisiana used to watch hbo and he
used to watch the y
yeah i was like damn cause you know he
was in that world but um
ice was like man turn that off but then
when the boxing parts came on you know
in season five
yeah i was like oh that's kind of dope
and this i wasn't bothering at the time
but i love fighting
so i was like what they doing and that's
that's kind of like
why my dad put me in boxing because the
wire because of the wire and i like
every time i see uh
like someone fighting involved i said i
just throw punches he's like man you
need
and we tried karate and then i used to i
used to get mad and just pick the kids
up and
just slam them yeah let me and it just
hit me like bro what is this i was like
just fighting
right now he was like you two you know
how bad you are when you get kicked out
of karate class
at seven years old they kicked me out i
was like i'm keeping the belt
yes we went on the wire tangent but
we're talking about michael b jordan so
you saw him
in the stu in the uh in the uh he was
yoked up
floyd mayweather's first okay so i was
like oh that's wallace and then
a couple i didn't know what he was doing
there he was just watching and you know
one thing about michael b jordan once
he's
you know he gets into character and do
the research
right she's like so great at that so i
seen him a couple months later
i was like hey bro and he was with a
childhood friend of mine who i used to
box with in louisiana
got you he was like hey bro you know hey
talk to michael jordan he cool and
the guy my guy my friend is his corey
colette he's uh
his body trainer he's you know the one
who's getting them yolk right and then
uh
i talked to him it was cool and he was
like bro i like this you know it's a
good vibe
and then michael b jordan just like i i
brought up i was like
remember i called you wallace and
floyd's he was like yeah bro that was
you i was like yeah
and you know we clicked ever since
that's crazy yeah he seems like a
pretty pretty cool dude man i told him i
wanted to act this is how cool he is
right so i'm on a set
of uh creed i was like bro i really want
to do this acting stuff right
okay cool but i think you should be
boxing i was like you don't know
my life right so uh he goes all right
you want to act
so he he had his agent like send me an
audition for barbershop 3.
oh wow bro you know hey i have an agent
he like kind of worked as my agent
he was like hey get my audition give him
a look and i was like okay cool thank
you bro and for sure
i thought it was coming from michael b
jordan i was like i got the part
didn't get it didn't get the part i
don't even remember barbershop three
i just remember the first two the first
two were great
barbershop three was that the one that
nicki was in thank you talk that [ __ ]
kev do we know i don't i don't i don't
know i just know nikki was in one of
them yeah
eve was in it and she was in a bad one i
just don't remember
part three i think that some some
sequels come way too
like i feel like that one came way too
after
yeah i was like come on man exactly they
didn't want to really really milking
that
they should have had you in it man you
should have me and you remembered it if
i was in there probably they had tiger
with the dress like come on out of real
way tiger was in it tiger was in there
oh no that's right he wasn't there see
y'all didn't know i'm bringing up
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] you got dressed for
come on tiger had dragons had an
accident at that calf
oh hell no i gotta been on set like hold
on we need to delete all this [ __ ] i
wonder which if tiger's the worst rapper
or actor
that's fair but you know what he's one
of the guys that just stays around oh
for sure
he's like damn every time i forget about
him he come with a hit i'm like you
[ __ ] yeah he was out he was down
and out and then he had that taste and
then
now he's on pimping only pimping hoes on
only fans
yo he's got his little uh t-raw
agency is he really like showing
everything on there oh yeah he's up
there he's on there getting
sucked for sure oh bro i was on twitter
scrolling
yeah rapper i said tigers
yeah yeah yeah i pray i never get to
those times but if i do
there's no dick yeah well what's crazy
is tiger's not even like
like he don't need to do that he's his
attention is a mother
i guess he's running the bag up man wait
it's a bag oh he's getting a bag on it
oh yeah he's got his own personal only
fans but then he also like
he has like an agency or something it's
called t-raw tr
and they sign only fans girls
so i think he's getting i would venture
to say he's getting a cut of a bunch of
different girls only fans
he's smart he's so smart so i don't know
is that is that digital pimping
i think so it might be it might be he
just gave me
it's no different than i guess like if
you're like a
company and you you know sign models
like vivid or something
man i want to get signed by vivid i
thought i had my whole porn name because
i'm from baton rouge louisiana
what was your poor name to punish her
don't [ __ ] laugh don't [ __ ] laugh
don't get up don't punish her
don't leave me now wait come come back
come that's great that was a great thing
that's great that's a great ass name
like oh [ __ ] who gonna [ __ ] me today god
damn so
was this a serious aspiration of yours
hell no but again i was just like i
think
i think yeah i think when i was like 17
18 i think we all like yo i would
totally do porn we talked to the homies
like yo would you do that [ __ ] of course
i'll be on browsers
run it up bro i don't know
hey you might think i'm crazy but it was
like a porn
like site i used to love going to it was
like street street street latinas
nah nah nah that's a professional it was
like some amateur [ __ ]
where's like this dude would be having
like girls it was in harlem
street world porn yeah there was a few
of those there was a guy in chicago
there was a guy in harlem where there
was just some random ass dude
who was just [ __ ] neighborhood chicks
and he was getting like he was getting
views he was getting paid yeah i'm like
yo he had me thinking
and then i met brian pumper at the 24
hour fitness oh were you disappointed i
was like what the [ __ ] are you doing he
was in there recruiting
bro what year did you meet brian plumber
uh let's see
i'll say 2011-12 or something like that
that's when he came with the
oh that was like peak peak pumper that
was when he was [ __ ] turning out
lawrence fishburne's daughter oh yeah i
forgot about that
yeah you know he she had a pimply butt
yep hey a couple of times i loved
her video with that white guy in the car
um but it was
hey um so brian pumper when i met him he
was beefing with fab on twitter yeah
remember that he's because he's fabulous
he's called
calling brian pumper jules yep i was
like and he was a big dude i was like
hey bro you think you're going
and he was trying to rap he was trying
to rap and that's why i was like he was
like bro this was this is so funny our
conversation i was like bro you got fam
you know i like the hype people yeah of
course i believe in you
he was like don't worry wait till the
disc coming soon i said don't do it
please
just just all you gotta do is keep
[ __ ] all you gotta do to win the diss
is just [ __ ] a girl that look like
his baby mom or somebody and be like
yeah and we're throwing
this and wear a paper towel headband or
something like
a backwards jersey and a [ __ ] 5x
mitchell in there
yeah it'd just be like yeah just just
sitting like oh this dick feel like
street dreams
yo i met brian pumper at um i was out of
north me and my wife were at this uh
boba
place in north hollywood and uh we're
just getting
donuts i think or something okay okay
and he walked in
and i was like i told my wife i said
yeah that's brian pumper
who the [ __ ] is that i said he's a porn
star and that was when my wife realized
how much of a piece of [ __ ] i was
because she was like wait you know
that's a man you know his name i was
like you don't understand it's like a
like he's like popping for show so i was
like hey man what's up brian pumper was
popping man you a legend you know what
i'm saying
i swear to god this [ __ ] left
the boba place and got into like a 1999
[ __ ] toyota sentra that was filled
filled with all of his belongings and
looked like it hadn't been washed in
like seven
since it came out it was insane
wow bro he got into this [ __ ] it was
like the most
beat down car you will ever see someone
get into
and it was filled the passenger seat the
back seat
every single piece of space in that car
had some [ __ ] in it
i swear to [ __ ] god bro so the jury
is fake
of course and he still had the the crazy
thing is he had a chain on
the chain you died and he got in that
car and i was like
oh brian pumper down bad
bro you believe in that bro the thing
about it yo that chain is real
okay it's about you got to be hood rich
okay you get a lot of people
i was like [ __ ] obviously he got in that
car is none of your goddamn business he
jumped in there central with all his
[ __ ] like hey man hell yeah mario
goddamn [ __ ] you know what i'll do i
could be moving in the process of moving
i'm homeless brian pumper yeah that's
crazy yeah i was like i was like uh
that's crazy because i do know a bunch
of male porn stars names though oh you
do oh bro wesley pipes is my god
yeah back in the day was like shawn
michaels
uh sean michaels was popping uh not the
wrestler
no there was a guy named sean michaels
black dude [ __ ]
you know swain i mean obviously like
peter north
is a p peter north to og what was the
other dude i met i've met all these guys
at the avn's
bro me and adam lexington still yes
i just want you to keep guessing
throwing dudes names out bro me and
i was at the uh we're at the porn
pornhub award thingies
and i was at the bar with uh my friend
adam and uh
one of the guys from black.com was
getting a drink next to us
and i was like yo is it gay if i say
like hey bro like
i see you bro like you you doing your
thing bro like i'm
like i'm a fan like you know the dude
what if you did geek out
no no no i was just i was just like
what's up bro i watch your [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying like
that's kind of that's weird as [ __ ]
isn't that weird like hey bro you got
you got a great your dick is huge hey
bro hey
the white women you be thrashing them
[ __ ] yeah
i see you bro black.com that's all you
right there
you you you to be in black oh man
yo the most racist industry still i
think i think porn is the only industry
in which like
cancel culture hasn't really [ __ ] with
yet why
because like everything's so fetishized
like the fact that there's like
black.com
and it's like one of the biggest
websites in porn
black dudes just just dominating piping
and not just white women all women
no no no there's like like vicki chase
is on there vira i mean there's there's
definitely a lot of latinas on there are
you serious
uh tiana trump's been unblocked she has
yeah by the way shout out to her
i found out her through twitter i was
like man what's up with this team
she's got that twitter video where she's
like it's like pinned i'm talking about
deep throat and i she a little she a
little off a little bit
kind of girl and you'll find out like
whoa i interviewed her
and uh regularly yeah she's a very uh
entertaining human being let's just say
that yeah
i shout out to tiana trump um hey so
uh let's talk about what is going on
you're no longer on
the fighter in the kids what happened
all right i know everyone everyone wants
to know the unknown but let's just talk
about the gnome first
yes all right you have your podcast the
cutting shut out the cutting weight yeah
yeah
podcast the weight cutters and babies
you know i mean with me and i got justin
elliott
um and again let's just talk about the
the gnome first before we get into that
yes
um they said i you know they said
they come on monday mornings like yo
malik b he's fired
and started laughing right and and come
in and
i would never do that you know that's
poor character on their parts
right i mean just and again you watched
the show right have you ever yeah yeah i
i saw
i saw uh i probably catch like one you
know i went to high school with
chappelle
so anything he does i try to support um
but uh i caught the beginning of that
episode
yeah and again that's all you should
have watched but uh the the
then he tried to come back and talk
about my work ethic now i want to talk
about
you know the things that you know what
you see
let's just see let's just talk about
what you see in front of you if you
watch the fighter in the kids
right let's talk about people characters
now
i kept a professional the whole time
right you never would see me
you know talk over anyone you never see
me like uh
interrupt anyone or have a negative
attitude right just like i'll come on
your podcast
very positive every time right you know
but then you got these guys that turn
their back
talk over you you know don't acknowledge
you so i'm just sitting there sometimes
i'm like
you know and i don't you know when you
people have poor character i don't feed
off that
right you know i mean i like positive
things like you would like positive
things around yeah so again
i just just to go off that and then you
you can always act like
i'm happy they brought brian calling
back i'm happy about it but
i've been with brian the whole time well
i i do remember him talking about you on
the podcast before
he was off of it bro brian i've been
around brian brian knows i don't talk
behind anyone's back
there's no knowledge of me because he
knows my character right and
i've been around like even when he was
in the situation he he was before he had
to left
like once he left the show for the
allegations
i always spoke holly o'brien because
when he was around me i was like bro he
always had
he was a man of his word you know he did
what he said he was going to do
and i love that his character was
impeccable and then people asked me
about like why
you know what he do i was like i don't
know that's not that's not my affair i
don't speak on that
right i'm just telling you how i dealt
with brian right and brian kelly can
attest you can go ask him like what kind
of character malik is he don't talk
behind
people back right he don't do that he's
a man of his word and if he doesn't just
speaks on his character
but again he i'm pretty sure he won't
because he's a great guy i can't i can't
say the same thing for those guys over
there
you know what i mean because again what
you just like i said just look at the
known you know look at people's
character i'm always professional
so when you talk about you know get on
there and start oh he got fired and
started laughing
that's unprofessional of course you know
i mean like yo come on that just shows
and then just
like that's a negative i mean if they
want to be negative like that let them
be negative
you know and i i don't feed off
negativity i'm not a palace i'm not a
negative dude but if you
you know clap back and stuff like that
like you know what i mean you you put
like a smut on my rep i don't like that
and i gotta clear these negative vibes
like yo now they'd be lying and all that
no
oh you go to my podcast a lot of people
are like yo malik is so different over
here
what's it over there you know i mean
because i was like bro you go to an
environment
and it's just so toxic you know i mean
just like yo you know
you know even if off camera i'm always
professional right
and you just carry that and you just
hurt your own podcast so that's
i'm going to speak on that but you know
what i mean i don't i don't really vibe
with
that kind of you know
people you know because then we are we
are in the comedy world we got to see
these guys and i always built i'm a guy
that like i'm authentic
what you see is what you get i'm a
stand-up dude i have principles i have
valuables
i don't talk behind anyone back i don't
do that even if they did that i'm like
man you will not see any text message
of me talking behind anyone back right i
mean even when they did i was like man i
don't got that
you know that's none of my affair i
don't like gossip i don't talk behind
people back so
that's that's that's the whole
environment so i just want to just paint
get that negative picture
out of like yo mallet got fire and they
started laughing like kev if i come over
here
and i was like yo you know so uh kev was
like um
kev you'll never do that but kev cheated
on his wife right
right but but but they're doing he's
gonna no it's gonna be a great
they're gonna work it out and stuff like
that you'd be like [ __ ] what
right you know what i mean like that's
that's what i think of you you know and
i was like man okay cool but then i got
to get
clear all that around my name because
you know i mean i don't like that i
don't want any negativity around my name
and again i'm that's all i got to say
about that yeah i mean
i think um if you
read the comments which i'm sure you've
read a lot of people would say that you
put up with a lot of i wouldn't maybe
disrespect or
and or like you some of the things you
just talked about and i think that
um the fans clearly recognized or
noticed
the things you're talking about fans are
not stupid you can't lie to the fans
the fans see it like again they don't
they they if
if people were kept it professional the
whole time they'd have never noticed
you know what i mean so it speaks on
that guy character more than mine well
it seemed as if like
i feel like the vibe was that brandon
really never had like saw you as a peer
if that makes sense like saw you as a
equal as far as just like
i would like because again i watch the
podcast a lot so i just always felt like
you said you only watch one episode no
no no no no i'm talking about since
oh since then since that happened no no
i watch it but i catch about one a week
like i said chappelle's been you know
that's my guy but i i always kind of
felt like yeah like it was just like
like like it did just there was like
respect levels on the podcast and i felt
like
you know you were kind of an
afterthought a lot or like
you know yeah like you said like a lot
of the things that
that you were talking about like it
feels like the fans of the podcast uh
noticed as well well when i first got on
the fighter and the kids which was a
great opportunity so shout out to all
the fans
brought a lot of fans i'm sure too yeah
yeah but um
big platform yeah big platform and and
i it was just it was just like an intro
to who i
am so when i first got on there i'm full
of energy i'm full of light like i came
on here that's how i always i'm
a positive guy right i feed off
positivity and i think everyone does
yeah you don't want someone like you i
come in here all negative like this
podcast is
[ __ ] this is going to be a long one
today yeah i mean but again
and it's so you you go back to the prior
episodes right
and then go back to the later episodes
you see the two but i never changed
almost like it's like a transition the
energy of the show yeah
yeah yeah it slowly started to kind of
yeah i was i was positive the whole time
because that's how i am i'm not what you
see is what you get
you know i mean i from the outside
looking in initially it felt like oh
[ __ ] this is dope like everyone's going
on the road together
uh it felt like some family type vibes i
thought that
you guys obviously were kind of put in a
really hard situation and that's to
replace
brian callan who was probably the fan
favorite on the fighter and the kid
um and so you guys kind of came in and
integrated yourself in
and made it a a whole new show really it
was just felt like a whole different
vibe you know what i mean
but you guys did it well and like i
would just see you guys on the road
together and then obviously
you know you [ __ ] doing the little
browse performance all that [ __ ] like
it was like like it it just and then
like like i said but then you'd watch
the podcast sometimes and it'd be like
it sums off a little bit and
again it's just like you know just with
the brows i created a whole persona
rolly boy and then just coming up with
different creative ideas like you know
the news i try to have a news segment
and i never
tried to come and replace brian i just
tried to show the fans wine
you know it was tough because i used to
go on the road with brian right i know
brian for a whole year i was like man
hell yeah but again it's an opportunity
to leave
my career in a different path he
understood that he was very supportive
you know and um i didn't try to think
about oh let's replace them just bring
something
that will help and benefit the show and
then you know
did things like behind the scenes and it
was
it was uh a lot of people can't keep it
professional at all what was kind of
your breaking point where you kind of
realized like okay
i'm i'm i'm just gonna do my thing um
again i i i can't say it wasn't a
breaking point i just said like
days i'll just show up like man all
right bet you know something that over
time
has been building that you've been
thinking about doing for a while well
when i came in like oh this is his show
right this is his show i can't really
again this is his show yeah wrong man
make grown man moves that's what you
want but
i'm also a man and i say whatever i want
to say on my like on my
podcast what you see cutting weight by
the way shout out to the white cutters
and babies
um they uh on my podcast it's like put
like this
i don't like weak dudes around me right
so if we if it's any negative
like like to negativity in my podcast
circle
a cutting away podcast would address it
you know with you how you feeling today
like shout out to my guy justin like yo
and my guy ev and
all right lola behind the scenes like we
have like a great
foundation and i was like bro if you if
you if you know justin and i we talked
before the podcast because again you
know he's still over there in that side
and
i was like bro if you feel any kind of
way we have real discussions
i was like bro but i don't like weak
dudes around me and if any of you are
snake-ish and stuff like that lose my
number
you know he was like yeah like bro he
know he know how i am he know
what i put up with and i i tolerate i
don't tolerate disrespect
and um you felt disrespected at times
well behind the scenes a little bit
because i'm like bro you know
i don't really want to go into details
but yeah but that but i also
that's how professional i am right i can
literally get on the show
and turn it on some people can't you
know yeah i think with the regiment you
guys were doing too
it there has to i mean not just
obviously you guys are doing three a
week
yeah that's another thing when i got
fired not only did they laugh
then he talked about like podcasting his
heart you know three times a week that
can be rough on i brought him a grinder
you know i mean i
have [ __ ] like spoon fed from me right
you know everyone everyone know like how
hard i work i ain't got to really
you know speak on my record but you know
jeff garland found me at open mics brian
shout out to jeff garland
legend i love [ __ ] jeff that's my guy
but again he found me at open mics
and i i'm the guy who come back from the
road and still go to open mics and even
when it's podcasting going on like you
know brian calling
everybody know like how hard i was now i
remember hearing this the funny story
about you uh
over the pandemic i was listening to the
podcast and you went to some like random
like rave
[ __ ] race and this guy performed in
like a tent at a rave
can i tell you the story oh yeah i i
just oh okay i'm sorry no it it was it
sounded like the most random
because it was in the middle of the
pandemic [ __ ] middle of the pandemic
these people didn't get the notice
like i was up in lancaster matter of
fact shout out to lancaster
yo shout out to them and by the way i i
didn't know what a rave was
so when i get there and they go in this
goddamn desert and i'm
saying i got jordan union ones on i
didn't get out the car
bad bad wardrobe trucks they didn't tell
me that so again
for future bookers let me know so that
it depends on what shoes i'm going to
put some vans on or something hey you
know so bad the promoter
we switched shoes cause i was like all
right i'm not getting out the car he's
using
union once yeah i mean i paid a lot of
money for these he was like okay cool
we switched shoes i was like no no you
you get some other shoes i got some
hiking boots
i put those on and you get these nikes i
was like cool and i went in there and i
went in this like covet tent
and i was like it was so but you know
how it's so bad he was like i'm i'm i
don't care about masks right i'm i'm
like yo mass whatever right i'm yeah
athletic when i got in that tent without
a mask i was like
give me a mask give me a goddamn man if
i give me two give me two because
like what the they were on everything
now this is before the vaccine and all
that right
yeah i'm like yo this [ __ ] is like yo it
was it was bad
well it's crazy living in l.a so long
like you don't realize
that other parts of california are red
loki
definitely if you see stars in cali like
you look up and you see stories at night
it's a trump flag not too far away
you go up you up the big bear like god
it's so beautiful up here
then you bend the left trying to find
your cabinet it's like oh my god that's
a giant mega flag
what the [ __ ] is going on up here you're
like well [ __ ] all right
this is what it is yeah that [ __ ] is
crazy and it was 200
and i was like all right but i just did
it for free because i mean right right
right right
there yeah like i said it's my third
year in comedy and i know where i am
and just like hard work got me to that
point so the fact that they just
you know that look at that negative but
that's people character you laugh
and you tell these lies about like yo
mallet got fired
it just seems in general like i said the
regiment i mean obviously but but you
know even i even feel like you know
from a fan's perspective it feels like
theo's growing away from
like it feels like everyone's it just
kind of feels like a lot of the [ __ ]
going on feels super forced
now it's like it feels like it feels
because i'm a fan right
so when i watch it some of it feels like
everyone's showing up
at like it's a job today especially like
when
like theo like sometimes you could tell
when he's on the king of this thing
i feel like that [ __ ] wants no
part of that [ __ ]
i'm like yo theo does not want to be
here today he rather
uh interview a female truck driver in
nashville about
lot lizards or some [ __ ] i mean
obviously you built a lot of
relationships through the podcast though
did you have a good like brian you speak
very highly
of d was your relationship with him kind
of the catalyst that kind of helped you
slide in there did you already have a
relationship with
schaub or uh not brian no way brian and
that was my guy that was my catalyst to
get in um
because it was just like you know two
stand-up guys yeah you know and uh
every time we speak you know you know
professionally
and and without like behind the scenes
it was just always a mutual respect
right right right right and you know
brian is a good guy genuine he's a
loving guy
and again if i have any issue with him
you call him i tell him you call him
you know we hash it out like a man and
likewise so
yeah i think brian was a catalyst to you
know
how i got in it seemed like uh
i mean are you still tight with someone
like chappelle or is that kind of
where things kind of i mean i kind of
leave with those guys where they are
that's fair you know i just you know let
them do that i'm doing my own thing
yeah so the cut and weight podcast um
shout out to the weight cutters and
babies you know yeah yeah yeah yeah
you're working what are the things that
you're applying to your own podcast that
you've learned
because you've done podcasting at the
highest level now like you know what i
mean what are those things that you've
actually kind of been applying to your
own [ __ ] that you've learned from
from your experience with the fighter
and the kids um
you know we have fun you know i know
professional level certain things you
can't say but also i know
it it's uh you know what you put out
there is what people are going to
believe
right so again you know you come with
these characters you know i came with
like the love doctor and the rolly boy
and i just make up stories
and these people really believe that
they don't understand that it's just
yeah yeah comedy so people be like oh he
lied a lot [ __ ] it was a joke
you know but again that like i was like
oh you can't you can't really tell these
fans
like because then they really believe
like you know me and you hear them at
the shows
you know and i was like hey bro did you
really i was like yeah i said oh well
did you really
and all that and i was the guy who
always talked to like the fans and right
i go outside and now just like hey hell
yeah come back stay you know i mean
because
i mean i'm a people prayer i love people
i love that so
and that was a whole bit and i was like
bro i talk to people about relationships
you know that's why i'm the love doctor
apparently and i'm you know i don't know
[ __ ] about relationships but they
believe that
right right but again that's just i
think like you gotta
whatever you say the perception you put
out there on once it downloads and it's
on the internet or wherever they can get
access to
you better be careful what you say
because because it's hard to shake
that's hard to shake
you know now i gotta like build around
because it's just like you know
uh my name is kind of like tornadoes a
little bit like yo he just do be lying
no i was just joking i'm just trying to
bring creativity to the show like you
got to breathe something
yeah you know so but on what couldn't
wait we just
we really i'm very careful i let my guy
justin elliott i was like bro fly i want
you to be a star
right like yo you might you know it's a
genuine friendship
you just like have fun okay for the
people who don't know what is your uh
is the give us the big sean backstory
let's talk about it
yeah you still call him that call him
little sean in my eyes
uh yo big shawn low-key yoked right now
though
yeah that's what i'm saying he is joke
shot of him that was just a joke bro so
um i was on the podcast so it's my my ex
um she used to work at this restaurant
and she was a hostess
he came in and i remember i used to pick
her up from work and i was picking up
that one day
and uh i guess he i don't know i can't i
don't say the year but i don't i can't
remember the year
but um uh he slid her
his number hmm how was i i mean what a
handsome tip you know i was like you
[ __ ] with money you know
you know how beautiful that girl is you
know she's gonna you know he hopped in
that goddamn bins
and then she came to me and you know i
don't wanna put my minutes out there but
i was driving this a center that's not
at least you were driving the brian
pumper mobile
well goddamn i didn't have my clothes in
the car [ __ ] okay okay he said i
had a house at least
yeah [ __ ] it was clean it was clean no
notes i had no notes on it
well no what kind of notes that man
paying on it was his release i own my
[ __ ]
uh nah but uh she got in the car and
uh you know of course you know she go
she's gonna do what you do so
so she texts did she text big sean so i
i was so she was like man like i'm going
out with my friends one night
right and i was all right cool do your
thing i ain't tripping it is like one
o'clock i was like i haven't heard from
my baby let me give her a little dial
so i called her he said boy no
hey no it wasn't it wasn't it wasn't it
was going straight to voicemail oh
that's yeah that's
like texting her and it wasn't i was
like is her phone off right
right then it finally came back on i'm
calling her calling her and then i'm in
the car at this point
and i'm going by her crib and you know
she live it was like she lived on
imperial way at the time
and it was like uh uh you can see her
car parking spot yeah like from the
street so i'm driving by
it's still i'm like she ain't home yet
and i'm circling like i'm patrolling a
little bit
you know i'm this young guy i've been
there i've been there she and then she
butt down me back
i heard it all ass ass ass ass
i'm like you [ __ ] you know what
i mean but you heard big sean
on the phone i heard i heard i heard her
all i heard was
you want to have another drink and then
i was like she was like yeah sure i was
my heart sunk into my goddamn stomach it
went to my goddamn stomach i was like
i was in the car i just you know how sad
you is when you just get out the car
turn the hazard lights on and just start
walking with no direction yeah i know
where i was going
i was just i just needed to walk and
then i i finally got back to my car
because
i mean that that was a short walk cause
i was in the hood and um
right he's like you know what bad
decision
let me go back to that center i'm trying
to go back to that guy where it's safe
uh
i could cry in the car yeah yeah you
want to you'll be sad air rob
you know yeah and yeah that was that was
a whole thing
but uh and i just kind of like i just
leaned into
um you leaned into it well at least big
sean helped expose the relationship that
probably wasn't gonna last either either
way right yeah because
yeah the reason why they call him uh you
know
your ex you know yeah yeah she was bad
though
she having only fans now nah i hope so
if she hadn't only fans would you
subscribe to your ex's only fans
ah because yeah i mean oh man i already
know what that looked like you know i
mean
i'm cool on that because then you know i
mean you have feelings and i'm like no
i'm good on that
you know again but she bad though nobody
now she ever say hi to me again all
is forgiven i swear i'll just mess with
you um now that like uh
you know you've been touring throughout
i mean [ __ ] there's been parts of the
country that have been wide the [ __ ]
open most
florida yeah texas yeah
phoenix yeah yeah um but but like
how like you know i always hear
comedians talking about like having to
kind of work out like it's like
kind of keeping sharp but you kind of
throw i feel like you you
pretty much were performing most of the
lockdown right like you were on the road
a lot
yeah i didn't i mean honestly i didn't
know it was a
the country was closed i was in i always
felt like i was from atlanta
right we go to these places it's like
bro i just want to go back to work i was
like [ __ ] can't relate and uh
yeah i just do my thing yeah we went to
atlanta uh in january and that [ __ ] was
crazy for all-star no no no no no no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no no i
ain't time come on
go i'm i'm not that's i'm straight i've
been doing the all-star weekend thing
enough in my life i don't need to
[ __ ] go to atlanta in the middle of a
pandemic to see what it's talking about
no it's crazy but now we we just went to
atlanta for some other [ __ ] and
it was uh yeah it was crazy it was like
wow
it was like being like because i've been
in la the whole [ __ ] pandemic and
this [ __ ] is
one extreme going to atlanta it was like
yeah it's wide open this [ __ ] is crazy
can we talk about something
yeah speaking of atlanta uh uh my
favorite rapper right now of course is
poo sheisty
shout out to poo shout out to poo i love
you he's from memphis from memphis and
i'm from the south so i wrote i wrote
you know big brother
i root for anybody like in the south
like if you're a south like my favorite
rapper
i just like yo you especially if you're
from louisiana like nba young boy
kevin gates i used to box with kevin
gates
very weird guy i was well he wasn't
weird at the time
he's an extremely intense human being
yeah
this i knew he was like throw it off
because we used to oh he's
he's a little off but he's a great guy
though he's so no no he's very
like i've seen him walk through a club
in tampa florida when i was doing radio
in tampa
and sold out club walk through
the entire crowd and hug every single
person in the crowd it was the
great i mean it was awesome but then i
did i did it
i did an interview with him uh in like
2018
and my co-host like like was like
talking to him and like put his hand on
his shoulder
and he was like yo don't touch me it
went viral as [ __ ]
it got cr it was he's like yo i feel
like i'm in prison still
you guys are interrogating me and we're
like bro what are we we're talking about
your music you're here for an interview
i'm saying what the [ __ ] do you think
you're here for you know when you go to
prison man you just like you trying to
sh yeah shut the hell up i'm talking
about this is this is when he was young
though
but i don't know about anything but
you're talking about pooch is that your
favorite yeah my favorite rapper
he just got caught with uh yeah now did
you see that hand did you see that
gargoyle hand
on that man like stomach yeah that's not
my man pool is it cause again i
understand like my brother called
it's so funny about when real dude so my
brother locked up right right and i put
him on pooh scheisse
he was like he called me he's like i
didn't know he was like man they got him
i was like whoo
they got poo they got they i was like
did he locked up he was like nah man the
man ladies just
i was like man you can't say man lady
big dog he was like man i'm in here what
am i
saying i was like no he was like bro it
ain't him right i was like i don't know
that ain't something he'll be
um you think that's you so i
i don't know i i i saw uh somebody on
twitter took a screenshot of the chain
that was in that picture
okay and compared it to the chain that
he wears all the time and the o's were
different
okay okay so it wasn't him so they're
saying it wasn't him oh you better not
because then
again it's just like yo you look at
someone different well again
we i support everyone yeah whatever
floats your boat or finds your lost
remote if pushed heisties atl
hey if poo if poo sheisty is uh you know
hey listen man but again it's so bad but
but but he's denied it and according to
the twitter detectives it's not him
exactly
but again and every some people thought
it might be big scar
wait hold on now no so he he did a video
on his story where he pulled his
shirt up and there's a big scar down the
middle of his chest okay she's like
[ __ ] it wasn't me
i'm about to say cuz i love that grim
reaper album that [ __ ] was hard i mean
he's a sleeper yeah i don't know man i
think um
this is killing the game right now by
the way it might have been someone who
just had the 1017 middle of the mall
chain
you said you said
you're saying these knock off
[ __ ] like man i'm to get hot
and she
she kind of lies she's like your
favorite rapper like i'll tell you this
whoever it is
if it's someone in gucci's camp they
already know it's him like they're like
come on bro what are you doing yeah
chill bro we're gonna have to cover this
up yeah i mean and look there's no shame
in
your s whatever you're into sexually you
know uh i i think that it's uh
unfortunate that somebody would try to
expose somebody
uh but again we live in that area it's
clickbait
whether or not it's a trans person or a
woman we've seen
most of these [ __ ] got whole ass
careers most of these females
have whole careers and my careers i use
that very loosely the followings
because they've i mean you'll see a
[ __ ] take a [ __ ] selfie with akon
sleeping next to her in bed like like
okay what's the point yeah you
like it [ __ ] happens like selena powell
all these [ __ ] [ __ ] all these
horse skis bro
if i ever get that famous and you see a
dude trying to allow me
and they got like a mark henry hand on
my titty or some [ __ ] oh my
gosh it's not me it's not [ __ ] me i
don't know anymore henry's [ __ ] yeah
that was stronger
that was a serious hand that was a big
ass hand yeah
that was a serious i was like oh she
look like she just got finished lifting
weights yeah yeah
i look like what remember remember uh
two wong fu thanks for everything wesley
snipes
when you cross dressed with john
lucazamo that looked like that that
looked like wesley snipes hand in that
movie
you ever seen that movie i've never seen
it it was west west it was wesley snipes
john lucazamo and patrick swayze and
they're all cross dressers
what was the point of the movie i think
that they didn't start out as cross
dressers but they ended up somewhere
where they kind of like became drag
queens
my mom loved the [ __ ] movie when i
was a kid what to get in the nba is this
johanna man or some [ __ ] that's that boy
that'll be reason
some of these movies in that age very
well like joanna man's one of them
you're like damn they made this someone
said yeah
that gave you listen did you hear about
the bill like you know i mean uh they
try to get like trans
uh like women to get like you know
transgenders
into like sports sports yeah so i'm
happy dope as hell
if we have like uh this is what i would
say
and and and and uh you know
hey what up man how to interrupt the
bootleg cab podcast to tell you
about our good friends at odd socks all
right
yo shout out to them for sponsoring the
podcast but also we're being
such a fire company and they just
introduced
their draws that's right
odd socks now got your boxer briefs on
deck
some tapatio joints and then of course
they got the best socks in the game
look at these stone cold socks look at
these two i mean look
i love froot loops but i love these
froot loop socks these are fire i'm
taking those for myself
uh they got all the licenses breaking
bad mac dre
odb wwe street fighter whatever you want
they got
including these draws i love these draws
i got some on right now
so listen tap in with odd socks go to
oddssocksofficial.com
use the keyword bootleg cab and you will
save 20
off at checkout so oddsoxofficial.com
keyword bootleg kev
save 20 to check out fake me later i'm
ex i'm obviously
i'm a pretty extremely liberal guy for
the most part
uh on all things except for guns uh
i hate the fact that it's so hard to
[ __ ] be strapped in california it's
it's
fresh you agree you want to be strapped
yes
that's yeah that's crazy i love but i'm
a liberal dude like i
you know i i've loved bernie sanders and
but i just it's so hard to protect
yourself and cali it's like bro like
oh we gotta we gotta okay let's just i
don't like the narrative that
that black guys like with guns
should be terrified like no i mean
listen me and killer mike have talked
about this a bunch and killer mike gets
a lot of [ __ ] cause
he's one of the few like uh second
amendment have
like big advocates in hip-hop
um but i think that especially in your
you know the african-american community
if anything the trump
trump era of this country and even
before that you know all the hate that
happened during the obama years i feel
like man
black people should be strapped up
because [ __ ] is crazy right now
like the level of like comfort that
racist people have nowadays
is like at an all-time high you know
what i'm saying so like
rather have it than not you know what
i'm saying like you never know when the
next
uh you know situation happens it ends up
on [ __ ]
the internet and it's like yeah i think
i think that obviously the gun control
thing
you know it should be harder to buy like
an ar-15
but like i mean in california it should
like you gotta shoot a [ __ ]
rubber bullet first so someone broke
into my house with a gun
yeah oh i gotta hit them with a rubber
bullet first
are you serious there has to be proof
that i shot a rubber bullet first
and then i can if they're trying to kill
me shoot them it's too late
bro and if you sh if they don't have
proof like you could have somebody
on your living room floor with a [ __ ]
machine gun
and a [ __ ] knapsack full of [ __ ]
hog ties and all kinds
of [ __ ] and if you shoot them you're
going to jail for murder in california
that's [ __ ] i didn't know that yes i
didn't know that well
if it's a black guy bringing it to your
house i understand it because black guys
can't aim
let's just
i'll tell you this i i tell you this
black guys in movies can't aim
and tv series first of all nobody in
mood bro that's the most unreal
[ __ ] nobody could ever shoot
anybody in a [ __ ] movie
i i'll give you one better watch a rap
video you know yo i'm pretty
sure your fan base is a lot around yeah
watch a rap video you see all these
young guys waving
there's like 38 people waving guns and
you i guarantee you'll never
say hmm that's good for him you'll never
say that because he turned the gun
sideways and bite his bottom lip for
more power
i'm like bro it's not that's stupid
though again
my brother like i've been around people
with guns and stuff like that and i'm
like bro why are you
yeah they carry because they're in that
world but as far as like you know
i get what you're saying you should be
strapped now i understand that you
should just have the like
you know you can't even be strapped now
in these laws because if you're reaching
for something you know it's just
that's a and even if you announce it i
got a gun in the car
like bro it's just tough that's why like
some of the more conservative states
like the fact that you could kind of
like just
have a gun on you and it's normal like i
feel like you know arizona's like that
i feel like i don't ever hear people
getting robbed like that where i'm from
and phoenix is a hood-ass city like
there's a lot of cartel [ __ ] and there's
you know the mexican [ __ ] is popping in
az
but like out here you hear people
getting robbed every [ __ ] day
on melrose and west hollywood and
beverly hills
like it's easy target so what do you
want to do you can't even
you know what i'm saying like but you
were talking about the trans thing like
the
idea that uh they're oh yeah in sports
and i mean honestly let those people do
what they want to do man
so you think it okay hypothetically
speaking okay
good lebron james yeah let's say
tomorrow lebron's like
guys this entire time let's say he has
listen listen lebron's the only male in
the world
whom i have a man crush on um okay i got
you but let's say lebron was like he had
his bruce
bruce jenner to caitlyn jenner moment
and
you don't even need that just put a wig
no but he just said you know what guys
this entire time
i've been unhappy because i'm a woman
inside
and so automatically at that point in
time
lebron is identifying as a woman he goes
in and he you know he goes the whole
caitlyn thing gets his the michael
jackson [ __ ] popping on his face you
know
shrink nose i don't know what that what
the [ __ ] else right
is it fair if if lebron goes and plays
in the wnba
is it i'm just asking this she's
basically saying king james be queen
james
yeah and he goes straight over to the
[ __ ] sparks
and just like [ __ ] duncan triple
doubles
talking about brittany greiner you don't
tell you wouldn't tell me that's in more
entertaining right you don't think that
entertaining of course so why are you
again so why are people against like
transgender and sports then
i'm not i'm not saying i didn't say i
was against it oh you just don't want it
i'm not saying that you're putting
[ __ ] words in my mind i'm just saying
you're over here
disgusting so what i'm trying to figure
out though
is is is is it fair to all of the women
in the wnba it's not fair no it's not
fair
but again and then the other thing too
is fighting right yeah oh did you see
that fight
yes that was so messed up so that is the
thing is like
it almost seems dangerous you gotta cap
it you gotta cap it you gotta put a
limit
like put them in like could there be a
like a transgender fighting league
that's kind of lit that's kind of lit yo
hell yeah i like
because there was that that i think
there was a transgender
uh combat sports yeah where no no no no
no no there was the the girl who was uh
transitioned
and was just beating the [ __ ] out of
everybody oh yeah i was like man like
beating the [ __ ] out of that
yeah that was messed up i ain't like
that that [ __ ] pissed me off the problem
with that is is if you say that
you're automatically uh transphobic
and that's not the case yeah i [ __ ] with
trans people like i [ __ ] with
but but it's just i feel like that's
that's what sucks obviously you're
you're you're comedian too which is
great
because comedians you guys could say
anything no we can't they can they can
cancel left to right
yeah but who's getting canceled
tim dillon didn't get cancelled but he
came up you know he got a shield over
him
what's the shield i think he uh everyone
i think everyone knows he's gay
yeah he's gay yeah yeah you want to put
them in yeah but do you think that's a
shield
yeah because once you i think you have
opinions
he's a white male andrew scholes some
crazy [ __ ] on flagra too
the craziest [ __ ] ever and i'm like i
love that's why i love it because i'm
like that's
one of the funniest people ever i think
tim dillon's the funniest man alive
right now right now i don't think
anyone's funnier than i
[ __ ] agree 100 like i i
man that dude is a [ __ ] he's a genius
he's an alien bro yeah yeah well his
i'm like how did he think of that and
what i love about tim dillon
is that he he's like you said i don't
know if
everyone knows that he's gay but the
thing is it's dope about him is like
most comedians that are gay you know it
like he just is a funny dude who happens
to be gay
and the other dope thing about him that
i love is like you never know like
what side of the political spectrum he's
on because he just kind of shits on
everybody both sides yeah it's great
[ __ ] funny yeah
and it's just i i listen i watch him
more than saying
like the news a little bit i'm like his
[ __ ] is hilarious
because he gives you it's like you know
he don't play to the left he doesn't
play to the
right he calls out both parties on their
[ __ ] he's a [ __ ] titan
that's why yeah but yeah to your point
um comedians yeah we gotta
we gotta sense there's some things we
have to say but for the most part you
guys can
let a lot of [ __ ] fly that most people
can't yeah well i can say well no
rappers rappers can say whatever
not anymore they can't nah what you mean
you think do you think eminem could put
out the marshall mathers lp
no in 2021 no and that's why i think we
got to stop listening to eminem in 2021
he's like first of all who's still
listening to msa is that is that still a
thing i don't know i haven't been on
twitter
no but dude they they're broke there's
uh there's been so many rappers that saw
the baby
they tried to pull up old tweets or soda
baby because he was using uh
sweets i'm talking about like yo nah but
if santa baby dropped
a gay uh slur in a song or something
like that you remember i mean we grew up
as a different er and
again i always say this like you know
people trying to cancel like old movies
or like
old songs and [ __ ] like there's this yg
song
on my crazy life called meet the
flockers where he was talking about
meet the [ __ ] flock he was
talking about robin
asian houses yeah and so they they
removed it off of
this i think they ended up editing a lot
of it no no they re-uploaded it
but but it's like edited crazy now what
do you mean
like so so he was like you blanked a lot
of [ __ ] yes because they keep cash on
them here yeah don't stand up
so there was this huge like movement to
get that song just wiped off of
like the internet why because because
the asian hate [ __ ] going on
and obviously that's a big thing that's
happening right now but again it's like
if you do that you open the pandora's
box
and and and that song came out in 2013
the m m shirt [ __ ] somewhat came out in
2001 2008
man i used to like just imagine you play
role model
like right now bro the song kill you
he's someone raping and killing his mom
i know which is crazy he has some demons
but again i think that you're right i
didn't know they were sensing
they don't want to listen to hip-hop
anymore if they doing that i said listen
i knew it was bad when they [ __ ]
tried to cancel
sesame street did i hear about that yeah
yeah i'm like what the [ __ ] and then you
go look at it well you know what oscar
grouch is a little pedophilia so i'm
like well
you know but yeah what was the thing
that they just tried to cancel cook that
we were talking about
the bunny lola bunny oh no oh yeah that
was crazy but no um
[Music]
they're like yo rape culture i said man
it's pepe le pew this [ __ ] was written
in the 70s and 60s and [ __ ]
he was old creep who gives a [ __ ] like
they took him out of space jam
that's crazy you imagine you waking up
him waking up that next morning like
what the [ __ ] i do
me and me tell me i was acting the same
way all these [ __ ] but you y'all just
caught on i was [ __ ] trying to [ __ ]
now
yeah man y'all some [ __ ] out of work
90 days
um you say you're a big lebron fan i
love lebron
lebron is my favorite player ever he is
the goat you're a laker fan as well i'm
a lego fan
you know he moved to lakers for me right
right right so i got to ask you this
because
uh that's an odd fan base to be a part
of both
what do you mean because historically
laker fans
are delusional kobe bryant people who
hate lebron
so when lebron came over to the lakers
it kind of it kind of
a lot of people's like membranes just
exploded because they're like what do we
do now
yeah we got now he's a laker we gotta
[ __ ] with him yeah
well i think yeah i was never like that
because i love kobe i used to watch kobe
my dad top ten all time i said i got him
top
he's number seven for me i respect seven
seven's a good
spot but again you talked to most
laker fans no they got him one
they they got that they got that
[ __ ] greatest of all time
bro laker fans cowboy or kobe fans not
laker fans there's kobe fans
there's cowboys fans there's little
wayne people
and there's tupac people
those four people you just there's
you can't say anything to these people
don't say anything about wayne
no no lil wayne's one of the greatest of
all time but
but he's a little
whoo lil overrated just a little bit
overrated
as far as what and acting cause he had
horrible movies i mean
think of like i want you to close your
eyes and mind you
of course of course of course baller
block classic though but
if you think of like wayne's discography
right and and mixtape wayne is a whole
nother story all the droughts and
you got to put that no no no no no i i'm
factoring all that in
okay even all the like the carter 3
leaks and all that were [ __ ] amazing
but if you think of wayne's first few
albums it was
it was uh the block is hot
there was one in between um 400 500
there was
500 degrees there was a one between
those two
i forget the [ __ ] it was called then the
carter one which is when people i think
finally were like oh [ __ ]
wayne is this dude is for real it was
the block as hiding as the second one
yeah the second one was different it was
almost like some electricity on the
cover of some [ __ ] yeah
i forget damn but anyways what you're
saying
so what i'm saying is with with wayne
the great parts of wayne are amazing
all-time great
but there's so much [ __ ] that wayne
has put out over the years
especially since the carter 3. i think
no ceilings in
09 was the last
project from wayne that i thought was
like and that was him rapping over other
people's beats
yeah where i thought he was like elite
since no ceilings
i thought carter four was okay oh carter
i mean yeah you can say that because i
like you not that's on him and t
i am not a human being the the revolver
bro all that [ __ ] is whatever good
singles right
love she will love great singles on them
but like
bodies of work bodies of work
yeah well look at what i can say the
same thing about jay-z and i love hope
what can you say about jersey so that
4-4-4 album was that was that legion
was fired oh it was i mean i enjoyed it
but see but see the thing is though
is i love jay-z but think about it think
about lil wayne
i just said in 09 in my opinion that was
when no ceilings came out right
he's been putting out a lot of mid
in in in weed in weed references a lot
lots of mid for uh
12 years let me just tell you something
kev
he's balling you know did you think
carter five was good no but
okay okay okay did you think revolver
was good no okay
okay okay did you think i'm not a human
being
was good i didn't listen to it oh [ __ ]
you didn't listen to it okay
cause he's balling he's putting out he's
going to the booth
with a wizard's jersey did you listen to
funeral last year
well mahogany was kind of hard okay okay
okay okay so one song
okay again kev he is he has his michael
jordan wizard
jersey on he's like so he's in the pools
right now no i mean but that my point is
he was only on the bulls for about
four years that was carter one
serious four years bro you can't put
like you have
seven straight hardcore years and we can
name them
no no i think yeah i think you go you
carter one
two and all the the the uh all the
[ __ ] mixtapes yeah
and then carter three seven oh listen i
think it was about four to five years i
wouldn't give
what year did i was in high school when
the first carter came out let's google
that hold on what year was that
was that oh five i think that was like
oh four right oh four because oh
six was the card of two oh four you're
right
june 29th oh four so yeah i was just i
was a junior in high school
so so from 04 to oh nine oh man five
years
you gotta go because i in high school
was when i got out of high school i
graduated so you you were [ __ ] with
500 degrees
yeah i was [ __ ] fine really yeah
where are you i'm from louisiana of
course i mean
yeah so a little wake and fart on a
[ __ ] like i'm saying like
like he did he was trying to insinuate
that his music was like
i'm saying you thought 500 degrees was
good i'm actually quite yeah yeah i
thought i thought it was good
for that time again now it does does it
hold up
no but other albums do i thought the
squad up [ __ ] was dope i thought
obviously
all the mixed i mean i think weezy like
mixtape wheezy is the best
little wayne there is but because 2010
no ceilings uh no sellers came out 2019.
he put out another album in 2010 i
forgot
uh another mixtape i forgot the name
that was hard so again i said from 2000
i'd say from 2004
no no because you caught in the car to
one i saved from so you're counting 500
degrees as a bro
part of his run i'm calling so the block
is how was it fire
i got an early call from keisha kisha
wanted me hit me huh come on
it was cool it was cool but it wasn't
like uh dude i i i think if you're going
to start putting people in that greatest
of all time
conversation well i said well he he's
one of but the greatest of all time is
drake let's just get that out the way
now now we can talk about longevity we
can bring up albums we can bring up a
lot
listen i cannot uh what based on
success yeah i can't argue with you if
you say that
no i personally don't agree and i told
you bro i met drake last week
me and me freddie gibbs and drake were
at a bar arguing for two hours about
basketball and his catalog
i told drake to his face you don't have
a classic album and he literally cared
so much
this guy's hands are so soft by the way
drake oh my god
[ __ ] shook this i was like it was
like [ __ ] dapping a pillow bro
you know what that feel like i feel like
a classic album no he got an aura he got
an aura no no no i think drake
i think drake is uh that's what it's
soft hell yeah i think for me
to me the black the black eye on drake's
career is the obviously the writing [ __ ]
oh my god also the fact
pusha t got in his ass and he did not
reply
don't be he you hear the dopey uh
freestyle no no no no no but push your
teeth
that was record one then pusher replied
and then how long do you want to beat
the silence how long do you want a beef
to go on
i mean you should ask drake that
question because he sure did carry that
meek mill b for a while how many records
did we get about me
i mean i mean now he got three
[ __ ] there was three there was
three we don't care there was three
will call charged up because there was
charge up they're looking for awesome 16
there was [ __ ]
back to back charged up charged up was
like a little because he said a little
few bars and i don't think that was a
bit
hey go listen to uh [ __ ] the takeover
by jay-z that whole song's not about
knobs there's like two bars about nas on
that but we
took that and he had ether so again it's
more
it's like give or take no no listen
drake is one of the greatest of all time
who's your greatest because you ain't
music so i have a i have a couple of
different
if you're asking me who's my personal
favorite of all time i just said who's
the greatest to you
no i think the greatest of all time is
jay-z and i can argue that i cannot
argue that okay
i think jay-z's kind of like like if i
to ask someone who's a basketball fan
who's the best ever and they say anyone
besides
jordan or lebron i can't take them
serious
yeah but there's only two right answers
to that question just saying people can
say kareem abdul-jabbar
you you have to listen you have to
listen he's third
but you have the those are the three
yeah also someone says kareem they're
probably like 68 years old
yeah but you can't we can't argue that
though but you could also just
i mean i think that competition i mean
like we could go down the basketball
rabbit hole but like no one's had no
one's had a harder than jordan or than
lebron
i feel you 100 but if you're someone
who's like yo who's your greatest of all
time you say drake
and i'm like uh i gotta listen you say
wayne i gotta
i can't if someone says wayne i'm like
okay then i i i i'm out i'm out
what i'm out yo you yo this guy and i
love lil wayne
i'm a [ __ ] fan i love wayne of course
but i'm also honest
i don't think so man pixel at all i
think this is the odd socks right here
i see the odd of you no wayne is a goat
for sure he's top 10 top 15
you know 15. yeah are you serious oh my
god
bro yo you're trying to make me walk off
the set you put drake above wayne
you put jay-z above wayne you got to put
you got to put biggie above wayne
you got to put nas above wayne uh i mean
you can zero down on us oh please don't
even slow down on us
i can put my i could put lil wayne uh
disography
against naz you're on drugs you're on
drugs
illmatic alone will [ __ ] on anything
little wayne's ever thought about making
hellmatic doesn't even hold weight to
carter too so
move on to that move on to that bro
you're [ __ ]
how old are you bro it don't matter
because i did you know when you start
speaking facts they want to bring up
your age it doesn't
matter that i'm 29 healthy by the way
this [ __ ] said what
yes illmatic i love az i love az life is
a [ __ ]
but i'm telling you right now illmatic
has
nothing as i was saying nas is greater
than little little wayne
uh i would put uh kendrick lamar above
wayne i'd put j
cole above wayne i would put
j cole just started how to how to make
hits he just found out when you're
listening to the board center
and you listen still don't make hits the
radio just goes to him which is what
makes him great he's never compromised
his sound yes he has no he hasn't yes
yeah
all those songs that got played on the
radio were all just regular records
that they had to play because he's that
[ __ ] no he didn't he listen
he used to produce his own music he used
to do his own piece and that was awful
it wasn't awful i used to listen to his
music when i want to vacuum the house
that's how i was like oh [ __ ] j cole let
me go ahead and clean up this [ __ ]
that's what kind of motivation i got
from j cole music bro no that's no
no role models is was a smash off of off
force those drives it's not a radio
record no no that's wet dreams not a
weighted radio right so you can if you
go to sideline story go to their album
you can't
that most of that album was out already
that album was so [ __ ] like
leaked [ __ ] was what oh it's not as weak
now it's weird no no leaked
leaked oh i bout to say leaked no no i
was not a sideline story fan because a
lot of that song
a lot of those records are already out
night mr night's watch was trash
um bro but but born center was
incredible for lil wayne is crazy you
putting
tomorrow over wayne's the warm-up and
friday night lights
are as good as good if not better than
anything little wayne has ever made in
his life
and i'm not even a j cole stan you are
there's people who got j
cole's whole dick down their throat and
i'm not one of them now kendrick
it's not even a question kendrick will
wrap circles around little wayne
literally nobody want to hear no one has
ever had
like how many [ __ ] albums in a row
are classics from kendrick
lane could never a [ __ ] ever in
his life make a re
make an album as good as the pimple
butterfly he could never in his [ __ ]
life
hope to ever make a good kid mad city in
his [ __ ] life
it's a pimple butterfly i heard that
album and i just turned it off and i
started praying because i got to pray
for the future
that [ __ ] i'm like what the [ __ ] is this
[ __ ] is this a rapper man
you're crazy i'm like oh my god i had to
pray i didn't know what to do i was like
man should i
ramadan coming up i need to start
fasting and start getting close to a guy
i don't know
because when i listen to that [ __ ] i'm
like this is not rap
andre 3 000 is above lil wayne
tupac's above lil wayne no tupac's
tupac might not be a better rapper no
but he's a pop is greater
greater than wayne come on man you're
from new orleans
you don't know from baton rouge it
doesn't mean it doesn't have anything
that means [ __ ] you probably got
boozy in your top five nah busy's not my
top five
boosie not another i'm i'm being realist
like busy
is not gonna not he's not even no why is
everyone why is every rapper from your
hometown [ __ ]
just insane like i feel like baton rouge
hip-hop scene is so crazy
killing it right now baby they're
literally killing it i feel like
everyone's beefing with each other
i don't trust you if you're from
louisiana you haven't been to jail yet
if you rapping
and you feel like yo oh yeah i'm in the
streets and you haven't been to jail yet
no it's that's cap yeah baton rouge
everybody
was fire everybody i had to get listen
it's so crazy i had to get like
like i was like man fredo you know i
always want to rep the city you're
probably on that nba young boy and then
oh yeah yeah and then i heard they got
beef and stuff like that and i was like
man
i'm right one thing if i got beef oh we
got beef like my god nba young boy i was
like that as a kid i didn't [ __ ] with
jay-z for a couple of years
because i'm a nas guy oh yeah but then
you realize like man
this is stupid these folks don't know
who the [ __ ] i am exactly and then i
started listening to fredo bang i'm like
the dude is nice yeah fredo's dope yeah
i like him you know
he tripping about talking about like i
want a honeycomb show but i mean know
your worth
hey hey you might as well ask i know all
they can happen to say no someone might
say yeah i know but the honeycomb br
they're not paying for it all bang a
honeycomb
maybe there what maybe nah you tripping
nobody's paying
okay okay they're in a pandemic you
think somebody's going to give
fredo banging a honeycake let me tell
you by all means i want you to get your
money fred up i'm just like
let's be real a lot of these rappers are
cashing out right now because
uh live shows as
crazy as it sounds people are paying
more money
to go to concerts now so like little
dirk just did a show in phoenix was like
10 000 people showed up totally a little
dirt
to a little dirk show yeah like a dirt
concert really
and he had that little girl uh right oh
yeah yeah big brother
yeah big big big purr yeah apparently
she stole
uh that song from a gay dude that sounds
about right
what was the guy named sausage he was
like everybody take stuff from the gay
community
i was like they do i think that the gay
hip-hop scene is about to really pop
why you say that i just think it's going
to be a like you know we got conscious
hip-hop we got
you know trap [ __ ] as uh you know you
got i think that there's gonna be like a
genre that opens up where it's like you
know
it's it's it's going to be a thing
you're talking like it's a boomdocs
episode you mean when the boondocks say
he
the dude was like yo homies over host
and then it was like yo
do the homemade he was like a gay rapper
and he was like oh ticket he had dudes
dressing
so remember i thought it was when young
thug was coming out with skirts and
painting
nails and i was like damn it's all i
think young i mean
obviously young thug's not gay right but
i think that he's kind of like made it
i mean andre was the first guy to do
that yeah but with the new uh
generation i just think it young thug
has made it okay
more like to be yourself yeah in hip-hop
because he a gangster by the way
right and so i think that's what's dope
about what doug did was like
he kind of made it like he took a lot of
them punches to the chin
for just being himself yeah you know
what i'm saying like
you know he didn't care he didn't he
didn't give a [ __ ] yeah because he was
like and that's the thing when you know
yourself you don't have to validate
you know what you like no i'm a nice guy
like man no bro people the public see
so young thug didn't really have to
you know and young thug is [ __ ] um a
goat in his own right he's one of the
most influential artists of all time
i did the ski challenge on my instagram
one of the most talented [ __ ]
alive
man i always tell people like if you
listen like old young thug like
yo like young thug could really rap if
he wanted to really bar some [ __ ] out he
could do it [ __ ] that man
keep that mumble rap but i'm saying he
could do it if he wanted to yeah i still
listen it took me
three years to learn the lyrics to
lifestyle that's fair that's what i want
keep me in three keep me like one day
rich homie quan
r.i.p no but just [ __ ] man he had it
right there in the court yeah right
there right there babysitting that era
of rich homie quan and thug was so
fire remember oh yeah when they did that
little joint uh thing they did the joy
the rich gang project yeah rich homie
quan had a soda but he got [ __ ] up
because his record label [ __ ] blocked
him from dropping music for like three
years and he just
by the time he got out on the other side
his [ __ ] was cold yeah
it's it's like once you had a stall so
they wait i didn't know that why didn't
he had a beef with his uh his his label
and they
blocked him from dropping any music so
he couldn't even put out like mixtapes
nothing
and i mean think about it he put out
flex that went like double platinum that
was his last big record
after that the mixture he had a song
called i know i know no that was before
that and that was a young that was a
yogaty record
oh what about what about uh gucci mane i
heard she do some tricks with a mountain
no no he had some but flex was like his
last
so even he couldn't but no no he's put
out yeah i'm sure he did features
because he did like little dicky [ __ ]
but he put out
two albums three albums in the last few
years and no one's giving a [ __ ]
give a [ __ ] about it that's true like
and rich homie
who do you got all-time future thug
future or thug yeah damn i got thug
and i love futures but it depends
because in the club i want future
play future future's the greatest like
depending on what clubs you're going
through but
i'm not even a club guy but to me
future's the greatest single club artist
ever
you can [ __ ] a whole club up in certain
cities for hours straight on future
bro you know what's so crazy future uh i
saw him
and him and sierra at the time in vegas
and you remember that song i woke up in
the new book
when they dropped that the club went
crazy but he just stayed there
and all white drinking he was with his
glasses on
i'm like hey turn up he was like he
looked at me and just continued to cool
his [ __ ] nothing
baby mama's everywhere yo yo sierra
right there we all turning up he just
stayed there and just bobbed his head
i was like you know how cool you have to
be to look around i thought he was like
neo in them
in the matrix because he had the glasses
on i was like is it morpheus i don't
know he took the blue pill
and he just literally like looked around
and we all jumping up
and i was like man hurry up hey get to
the course yeah shout out to ace hood
man
hurry up hey you taking too long yeah
and i'm rich is a bit i'm like come on
come on
hey the only version of that song to
listen to is the remix though oh bro
yeah whoa yeah wait rick wasn't wayne on
the
remix bro i remember i was ross and
wayne was both i think both of them was
on their remix
i know ross killed that i was about to
say and push a button on this [ __ ] and
i'm like oh
boy i'm like okay ross ross is so great
on features
i think you talking about uh hustle hard
uh that's what i'm thinking of
yeah wayne yeah it was that's what i'm
thinking of that's what i think that's
why
it's not a song anymore yeah that's
facts because he once he once he came in
and started wrapping the chorus
oh by the way you want to know another
rapper that's greater than lil wayne you
just mentioned him
rick ross i love rick ross
come on man i love rick ross i just
gotta finish off the plane like
really reading his book hurricanes and
now i didn't know
his journey that [ __ ] is so [ __ ] dope
right
just like yo how he got counted out i
got someone trying i got someone trying
to wire me some money i got to send them
my address real quick keep talking about
ross oh you you know how goddamn money
was that a flex we
i love how you rich he mentioned rachel
mcquain is like
that flex was his biggest hit and he was
like hold on just keep saying that
little [ __ ] you talking about
everybody wired me 50k i'm like well
hold on now [ __ ]
sorry hey i'll check engine light on kev
i mean
nah ross is um i think ross like for
whatever reason doesn't get like
the accolades he just like deserves when
we talk about greatest of all time but
like bro ross
one of the most smoothest butters flows
ever it's so hard for him to sound bad
on [ __ ]
in my opinion the greatest ear for beats
in hip-hop history
oh production one of the one he pred he
surpassed jay-z in production yes i
think
and that's why i always wanted ross to
executive produce a nas album
because i wanted ross to come in and
pick all the nazi's beats cause i think
nasa later on in his career
who chose nice beats on his last album
that was dope i forgot his last time was
fire oh hit boy hit boy to the whole
album
that's what he needed to do was lock in
with hit boy so hit boy can make sure
the beats were fired
hey hey boy send me some beats man i'm
trying to flow are you gonna start uh
doing the you know i made some comedy yo
andrew schultz just put out the uh
opener up i know i saw that with uh my
guy jelly roll oh yeah
that's my boy i know that's my guy oh we
you uh we we
time yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's how
i knew you was solid
uh uh jelly roll is uh a great guy he uh
so [ __ ] funny he calls you bubba i
was like hey come on bubba
like is that the white n word i don't
know it's the white n word i think it's
i feel like it's the nashville white n
word it felt like it i was like
and it's like the first time you hang
out with jelly roll like i think i met
him in like 2013
2012 and he was throwing that bubble
[ __ ] and i felt i don't know i was like
you know it's like a puerto rican guy
called you poppy and you're like yeah
like bubba what the [ __ ] we talking
about i know that's what i'm saying but
it was so addicting and then
it's so addicting i came home talking to
my homies on the block like that
like bro bubble your [ __ ] nose you
better jelly roll
because the black guys you say hey bubba
come here like i'll beat your ass oh i'm
sorry yeah he's
he just got back from nashville i feel
like that motherfucker's got to do a
podcast or something because his
personality is so infectious like yeah
hey he killed it all king of this thing
with theo
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it was just
like he's just made for podcast
so his life is interesting and he's bro
he's watching he's just
you know that man living and he's solid
let me just tell you we had to go to a
barber shop
out there in the hood and he was like yo
just say my name and you're good
yeah he called up there and he they he
was like yo
you got you situated yeah guys i brought
no jelly rolls no [ __ ] jelly roll
he's like yo hey
these guys y'all just came from sushi
he's like yeah oh you all good
jelly roll you know i was like i was on
my thug [ __ ] uh you're a boxing guy
how are you you know like obviously the
boxing has had more attention than it's
had in
years um but but
how do you feel about like uh current
state of boxing obviously uh with
with all the celebrity [ __ ] going on bro
i love it i say keep it coming
i'm a big i'm a hey if i was jake paul
and i think he's gonna do it
no again i got my feet in both camps i
got my feet in floyd mayweather's
because
of course living in vegas and training
out there with floyd sparring floyd
getting to know him
that's my guy and then i got my feet in
the paul brothers camp you know my guy
jaylen love he was out there getting
into it with tyron woodley
and all that you know so you know both i
know both camps but
as far as jake paul i say keep pissing
these people off
i don't know if anyone's ever been
better at that you know
and he's he's winning he's strategically
calling out a ufc fighter
to come to a ring it's a boxing ring
right right right honestly i truly
believe
that a ufc fighter can't beat a boxer
in a boxing ring yeah you know i mean
and i i
you see it there's like oh ben he's not
he's the weakest
you understand boxing is time ufc
fighters fight with smaller gloves right
and then you you
on your feet all day like that's a lot
and the conditioning and he came out
there and he looked like a real boxer so
i say keep keep pissing these people off
do you think he's a good fighter
he's decent he's decent he's decent
that's all you need if like you
he's a great [ __ ] talker and he's i i'm
like i'm like seriously trying to
remember
who's been better at that part of this
[ __ ] no one to get under people's skin
like he and then he [ __ ]
got your hat i'm like bro that was the
most
merch because guess what now it's almost
like floyd has to fight him
no he's fighting his brother no i know
but i feel like now he's gonna [ __ ] his
brother up
then he's gotta fight jake paul's not
gonna fight him because then then the
bag will stop
exactly jacob because he will lose that
fight and he wants to keep that oh
so he's going to fight like they got
yeah they want him they want to milk the
bag as long
as they can yeah he might take the
connor fight
he might you might he'll take that yeah
he might win that
but floyd will [ __ ] uh uh
floyd i heard i heard right now that
floyd is looking so great in camp with
darante davis
and you know i'm we rolling with tank
all day but
you know floyd is out there just like he
keeping up with these young guys like
floyd can fight right now fight like
canelo a fight
pacquiao fight and give him a good fight
because you know once you have that
that that iq of like i'm i know this
ring i know it's almost like watching
chris paul play right now it's like yo
man like i don't think
chris paul could be 50 and he'll still
be able to the point god
the point that's what they call him yeah
so um
like with fighting i feel like obviously
canelo is the guy right now
yeah of course did you watch that fight
i only saw the whatever was on instagram
that uppercut you know what i'm saying
do you think he's been the best since
floyd he just all he did was take
listen this was i know exactly what
canelo did he watched that fight over
and over and over again
the floyd fight yeah oh that's what he
was doing to me let me just
adopt that style and i got punching
power and i'll show you so now he
doesn't get hit
he [ __ ] puts that in combinations and
then he's like
basically took floyd style and just like
ran with it and made it his own
made his own and that's that's what you
do and that's like man nobody beat
canelo
nobody like yo and i love caleb playing
that's my guy
caleb plant is going to give him the
best work he haven't seen in years
though
like you know i mean he ain't gonna go
in there like a lot of these guys
getting there you see 75
73 000 people and you get nervous oh i
said come on
oh [ __ ] i'm not fighting i'm fighting
canelo yeah you know and they're like oh
cuz now hello
you might hear me understand it's canelo
you know just viva la me i turn
real mexican when i'm in the crowd for
some reason
i'm like i believe to i'll just start
saying [ __ ] um
but he's the guy as far as like no one's
beating him no one is suppressing
now if he goes up or he fluctuates with
he goes down and fight earl spence that
dog girl
at 160 he might have some trouble down
there i say keep it
would you uh participate in any of the
celebrity fighting [ __ ]
hell yeah that's why i'm training you
yeah look cam i ain't training
for my goddamn health i'm trying to get
some [ __ ] i'm trying to get
deals too
believe in me please uh nah nah i always
i don't i don't think i need that right
now but if if the money makes this and
just like for bragging rights because
i'm all about my respect so
if it's bragging rights like hell yeah
i'll fight another celebrity now who
which celebrity though we don't know yet
um well there it is this guy uh any are
you i mean
obviously nowadays uh you know andrew
scholes has kind of proven you really
don't need to
get a netflix special you can kind of
shoot your own specials nowadays on
youtube and [ __ ]
yeah mark norman uh but i'm saying like
are you gonna be like uh
doing a any sort of special or anything
or are you still kind of
i'm still in doing i'm doing my own
thing right now i'm trying to do it all
like i'm i i'm doing stand up acting
shout out to xbox i don't know y'all
seen that commercial i'm in the xbox i
got another one coming out so be on the
lookout for that
um now i'm just i'm acting doing it all
i'm doing it all bro podcast why are we
limited to one thing
you know so again we got the platform i
look up to a guy named dc young fly oh
yeah he's great oh my god he's doing
music
podcast yeah dc young flies amazing yes
got a crazy work ethic crazy working and
i was like bro why
you know what i like about what he did
too was he showed everybody that like
you could pop off
on twitter instagram or whatever and
it like you know because i feel like we
see a lot of these guys come and go who
are
internet stars but real talent always
perseveres
like the 85 south show's so good bro you
got the og
carlos miller who've been doing it for
20 plus i remember first time saw carlos
or who
got jokes and i was like man it robbed
him you know you got chico bean i mean
you talking about music kind of stuff
i would love to see you and him have a
conversation because i mean y'all
brilliant
yeah dc young fly is a very he's like an
alien man that guy can do anything
anything and that's why i'm like man why
should you limit your talent so
uh you don't really need of course it's
like a good
you know thing to have when you got that
battery behind of course i'm pretty sure
with that but you know you can do your
own thing basically there it is
well uh the cutting weight podcast cut
it away podcast uh on youtube please
subscribe with my guy justin elliott
it's so much if you think you enjoy me
on here you're gonna love me on there
uh we put out every thursday on youtube
uh itunes
you gotta get brian callan on the
podcast we're going to bro we're going
to get them
that'd be good listen and how we you see
how we play off each other it's very
dope
we'll get my man on there uh we have
like so many
it's a good time if you ever like go to
a barber shop in america
and you like yo you talk your [ __ ]
that's how it is i'm cutting weight
you know it's for everyone so go
subscribe show them some love
and uh thank you for coming through man
thank you so much for having me keep
supporting kev you're a good dude boom